hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i will be your driver on this
journey
tonight i want to talk about a very fun
part of chess which is attacking
specifically attacking the king
um and i wanted to do this lecture uh
for a number of reasons but one of them
is always i'm uh you know the uh
the person who is always complaining
about
these stupid gambits that everybody
makes youtube videos about the stafford
gambit the whatever game but the
halloween gambit the frankenstein
dracula
the monster the monstrosities of chess
that are on youtube these days um and
those gambits will often lead to some
very fun games where you checkmate the
the opponent's king right out of the
opening
um but the best attacking games uh in my
opinion happen after the opening and so
i want to talk about some common ideas
some common attacking themes to look for
in your game specifically against the
castle kings so your opponent has
survived the opening gotten castle has a
normal looking position but still you
can crack it open and attack that king
you can have fun in chess without
playing the stafford gambit i promise
firing shots at rosen rosen jonathan
everybody i hate everybody um
just kidding they're all great watch
their watch their videos anyways in our
first game we have yuri razorback with
white against ivan ferrago
uh and we're gonna start with a queen's
gambit we get knight f6 knight c3 and c5
so we're in the terrace
there are a number of ways to deal with
the trash but white chooses to take on
d5
black plays knight takes d5 rather than
e takes d5 i think both are playable
and white responds with e3
we get knight c6 uh bishop to c4 is an
interesting idea uh we don't really want
to interfere with this queen's axis to
d4 just yet and we'll see that
pressuring this knight does have some
advantages
uh c takes d4 and then white of course
responds with e takes d4 rather than
knight takes d4 so we have gotten into
the alzheimer classic
iqp isolated queen's pawn
so of course
this uh type of position can show up in
a number of different openings both e4
and d4 uh there's sort of a
this is one of the most common positions
to get in chess one of the most common
structures white has the queen's pawn
that is isolated and black is fortified
against it trying to blockade it trying
to pressure that isolated pawn
but will suffer from a slight lack of
space
so let's play a couple more moves black
plays bishop b7 white castles and black
castles
uh and now right out of the opening just
let's test your iqp knowledge what do
you think white should be aiming for in
this position what kind of ideas are
coming to mind
how are we going to finish development
and start to have
a more concrete plan
any ideas
okay someone says se5 i think s means
knight
um
so yeah knight 95 is one of the ideas
trying to take advantage of
uh this extra space that that the d-pawn
gives us but
i'm more interested in you know a
bigger plan like why are we putting our
knight in e5 why are we doing anything
what is what is our goal in this
position
what is our goal here
how are we supposed to use this extra
space to our advantage
okay the chat's just giving some some
moves uh trent says rookie one uh david
is set on 95. trent also says 94 but
you're not answering my question what is
our goal okay gabriel says to push the
pawn so that's one of the ideas
that's uh we'll crop up in an isolated
queen ponds sometimes white tries to
play for this move d5 and with d5 we're
gonna trade off our weak pawn while
still enjoying a lot of the advantages
of the space that it gave us our pieces
would be better placed we can try to rip
things open some more and
attack once we we've opened things up
over there but
d5 actually isn't going to be our main
idea in this instance and the reason is
pretty simple black is controlling the
d5 square very very adequately there's
there's not much we can do to really
force black off of this d5 square and
black is even
going to continue with stuff like b6 and
bishop b7 to further solidify this
square so
although pushing the isolated pawn is
often a good idea that's not really
going to be our goal in in this position
james duggan asks is this a pan of
botvinic attack uh this one specifically
is not but i think you can get this
exact position in the pan of bodfinic
like i said there's
a number of ways to get to uh get to
these positions
james says try a3 bishop a2 bishop b1 so
that's more of what i was looking for so
uh why would we do such a maneuver well
of course the goal is to attack on the
king's side this is one of the super
common ideas
in
isolated queen pawn positions is you
want to somehow launch an attack on the
king's side
because that's what you can do when you
have more space you can easily switch
between different sides of the board and
in this case
white has these long open diagonals
looking at black's king and this knight
over here is ready to help our queen is
ready to help and we'll see that we can
even bring more pieces in into the
attack so
one of the really important ideas here
is going to be attacking on the king's
side for white now i actually don't like
the move that white played in the game
which was bishop d3 it's a very
straightforward move but it's sort of
missing the point of why we put the
bishop on c4 in the first place so
uh before we move on with this idea of
trying to attack on the king's side i
first want to just say rookie one is is
the normal move it's the main move this
is still a theoretical position
rather than bishop d3
but i'm curious if you guys can tell me
the reason why would we rather play
rookie one than bishop d3 what is the
point of having this bishop on c4
what is the points
any ideas in person audience
no okay
so what does the bishop do on c4 what is
it doing here
in d5 yeah it's pressuring d5 so so why
does that matter why do we need to have
some pressure on d5 here
okay so we still have e5 pretty much
under control like it's gonna be
difficult for black to play this move
and rookie one kind of achieves that
same aim anyways um
more importantly though black has to
finish development and to finish
development we need to put this bishop
somewhere and so because we have these
two attackers on d5 if black tries to
commit to something like b6 in this
position for example i think we are
actually just taking on d5
and the point is we've induced this
weakness on the queen side and since our
bishop is here to back up our knight
queen takes d5 isn't playable e takes d5
must be played and then this bishop is
no longer able to develop to this
diagonal so kind of an opening subtlety
there but it's important to understand
you know why we're putting these pieces
on these squares
um
because
if you don't understand this idea then
bishop c4 just sort of feels feels wrong
you know why not just bring the bishop
to the better square but
it's with an idea which is why i was
sort of surprised to see bishop d3 in
the game sort of missing the point um
and then black
right away misses the point back so the
main line goes rookie one and because
white has this idea of taking on d5
against b6 black generally takes on c3
first to get rid of this idea and then
plays b6 to develop
so of course naturally what is the best
move after bishop to d3 what should
black be doing here
hello hello to manny
also yeah welcome back everybody to to
the road to 2000. i uh i was off for a
couple weeks there with kovit but i'm
recovered now i'm safe i'm back in
society so it's it's good to be back
yeah you can just play b6 and i think b6
is the best move um
and the reason is now if takes
quite happy to take back with the queen
we have not locked in we have not locked
ourselves in on this diagonal and black
is actually going to have some pretty
significant pressure against white's
king
so some opening subtleties there that
were maybe missed um what i suspect
happened is both players had this
position
in their preparation
and when white played bishop d3
both players were like i can get to the
position that's in my preparation so
they just did it anyways even though
it's technically not you know the
objective best move so
takes on c3 was played anyways even
though now there's really no need to
and then b6 and then rookie one and
we've transposed to the main line
so this is a pretty significant change
in structure and it's actually a
favorable one for white in most
instances sometimes
black can claim that this structure is
worse than just having the isolated pawn
because there are two pawns on these
open open files
uh especially if black is able to for
example
set up a blockade on these light squares
and use the squares in front of the
pawns for uh for outposts for his pieces
uh however there's one massive advantage
to having this pawn on c3 and you can
probably guess what it is it's it's that
this pawn defends your formerly weak
pawn on d4
so now again there are multiple ideas in
the position for right
let's just play one more move bishop b7
this was expected
uh there are multiple ideas here one of
them is this idea of pushing the hanging
pawns is what they're called the hanging
pawn structure you can push them forward
and try to break through by playing d5
or playing c5 and trying to just push
your pawn
but i don't think that's actually the
best plan here
it might not seem like it from this
position but black's king is actually
going to be very very weak in this
position
and there's one big reason for it which
is going to be a big theme throughout
the lecture and that reason is there's
there's no knight on f6 the knight on f6
is a really key defender of the castle
king on the king's side especially and
without this knight here already you can
start to think hey maybe these these
pawns are a little bit weak maybe we can
set something up and attack on the
king's side
so after bishop b7
you might expect some kind of normal
move maybe even like bishop b2 c4 rook
c1 queen c2
uh these sort of long-term plans just to
play the position slowly but white had a
very nice idea in this game that proved
to be
rather difficult for for black to meet
so what do you think white came up with
here
white to move and launch a kingside
attack
okay rookie 4 is bold rookie 4 is bold
um
the problem i think with this move is
the h4 square is is going to be guarded
and you can come to g4
but
uh it's not quite working
fully in tandem with with the rest of
your pieces it does bring in another
attacker though
webster says g4
we'll keep this rookie 4 idea in mind
though because this is going to be
important
so we've got two ideas
rookie 4 g4
h4
um and manny is talking about playing on
the queen side as is somebody else
um
okay you guys are are very very direct
this is this is sort of what's called
hope chess so you don't want to play a4
bishop a3 hoping for bishop a uh hoping
for bishop takes a3 or takes c3 and then
the greek gifts because that takes you
four moves and it takes black one move
to stop the greek gift and so then he'll
play three useful moves in the meantime
and then you're in trouble
okay bishop b1 is on is suggested as is
bishop c2 with the idea of making the
battery
um just bishop takes h7 just do it just
get him
uh also suggested so there's a lot of
ideas so how do we
uh sort of sift through these ideas well
uh what our goal is here is yes it's to
attack the king
but also very importantly when black's
three pawns have not moved on the king's
side they're actually very solid it's
tough to sort of break up this structure
and sort of get checkmate and the reason
for that is they're very fluid you know
what black might move this f pawn black
might move this g pawn black might move
this h pawn depending on the threats
that we make so our goal kind of first
is to yes
make threats and try to checkmate but
it's also to induce these pawns to move
so that there are more weaknesses in the
position so that's why i think rookie iv
for example isn't going to be good
enough because rookie for rook g4
then you were threatening bishop h6
but it's still difficult to say how that
how that is going to provoke a weakness
for example let's say rookie 4 rookie 8
rook g4 bishop f8 bishop h6
um i might already be playing just g6
trading off these bishops and developing
and sort of defending adequately like
you can induce g6 with this plan but
black is able to guard these dark
squares with this dark square bishop so
we have to find some other way to force
black to make concessions on the king's
side force these pawns to move so that
we can weaken them we can soften them
and then uh and then crash through
trent is the slow g3 h4 and wipster says
g4 so talked a little bit about rookie 4
rookie 4 is sort of a normal looking
move to activate the rook but again it's
a little bit slow and it's only inducing
g6 which black can sort of defend bishop
f6 to g7 bishop f8 things like that
uh g4 i don't really understand the
point of at all i don't see how this is
really advancing the attack
uh
you know like g5 h4 h5 g6 is maybe an
idea but that pawn might end up actually
in your own way
uh outside of that you can't just be
totally blind to your opponent as well
uh black is getting very much ready to
sort of crush you on this diagonal right
this is sort of scary stuff if you start
moving the g pawn
so same issues with g3 on this diagonal
it is also just a little bit slow
and as far as bishop b1 or bishop c2 and
queen d3
this might be playable but you might
find that your queen is better placed on
d1 than it is on d3 and the reason for
that is this queen can very actively
jump into the into the into the king
side and if you spend your time uh doing
something like this
after g6 again uh now you might find
that your queen is a little bit stuck
over here it can't actually make its way
effectively into the king's side without
spending some more time
so what does that leave i think the only
one i didn't mention now is h4 and h4 is
the correct answer here this move uh
kind of surprisingly is really really
strong i think white is already
significantly better in this position
uh so let me ask the obvious oh okay one
more idea kenroy davis says queen c2
queen c2 is a perfectly fine move this
is the main alternative if you're not
going to go for you know crazy attack h4
you can play queen c2 uh pressure this
guy just a little bit and for example
after something like g6 we are going to
get these ideas that i talked about
where black is surviving on the king's
side because this bishop can come defend
some of these loose squares
uh with h4 that's going to be a little
bit harder for black to to maintain
so let's ask the obvious question what
happens if black captures our pawn for
free and then we're down a pawn so sad
what happens here
what were we up to with this h4 move
yes so definitely we want to take this
dark squared bishop and we can
arrive at that conclusion pretty quickly
right and all these lines we're looking
at g6 this bishop is coming back to
defend black's king and sort of
stymieing our attacks so h4 takes uh for
example
knight takes is already a huge win for
us because now if g6 gets played black
has you know big trouble big trouble
this bishop is going to come invade and
we're going to try to play for mate on
on the dark squares i'm sure you guys
have seen this before
you never want to play g6 when you don't
have the dark sword bishop and white
does have the dark squared bishop
because you know you just sort of get
demolished like this
but we actually do have a better move
than rook e4
um yeah just rookie three
and this is just incredibly dangerous
now for black uh immediately we have
this threat to like win the game with
checks
um which if you haven't seen this check
mating pattern before just to show it
off here
um check
check
and rook h8 amazing queen h5 queen h7
there you go
um so big threats already with rook e3
big threats so what is black going to do
well it's finally time black has to make
a concession on on the king's side we
have to play g6 or h6 if you play h6
here
um
i think again you're just going to be in
big trouble rook h3 for example queen g4
and this is very very difficult to uh to
stop very difficult to stop
uh just one more example line
uh that's a free queen
there you go
amazing hold for applause
okay um
uh of course you know this pin on the on
on the file is enough to win here and if
you don't unpin i'm going to take this
next turn and same checkmate as before
check check check check check
so really dangerous stuff which is why
black should play g6 here
but after g6 uh white is again just
going to be crushing on the dark squares
like we talked about rook h3 looks very
tempting there's actually a better move
in rook g3
and the point is it achieves the same
aim makes this queen move because if the
queen doesn't move again you're gonna
find yourself trapped
um and so after something like queen e7
we just play bishop g5
bishop h6 queen h5 and
uh this is coming very very quickly
for example f5 to stop it we just bring
in the rook bishop c4 like the moves
sort of play themselves at this point
and you know then you can sack and
calculate to your heart's desire but you
don't necessarily even need to to
sacrifice here for example queen h4
rookie three and and you just are are
going to win this game and i believe
this is this has been played before
yeah in some random game from the 90s
white played bishop f4 here and and won
very very easily
but rook g6 is good enough if you're
curious
so
taking an h4 not so good not so good you
get into quite a lot of trouble with
this nice move rook e3 heading to g3 and
and causing all sorts of problems
one last thing to look at if black plays
something like uh queen f6 we just go
rook h3
and we've seen this position uh before i
think or queen g4 and we've seen this
position before
with all the same problems
um so bishop h4 not looking so good not
looking so good and now to play h4 do
you need to calculate all that
uh i'm gonna say no and you don't even
need to have this like in your opening
prep so how do you come up with a move
like h4 and actually play it in your
game well you look at all these lines
like queen c2 g6 bishop h6
and you start to think to yourself
man this this bishop is is really just
preventing all of my play by by coming
back to f8 and defending um and so you
start to think well how can i get rid of
this bishop and you start to think okay
maybe h4 and i'm coming into g5 and if
black takes an h4 i'm getting rid of
this bishop and then you start
calculating a little bit you find rook
e3 you see some of these lines and then
you go from there and attack
so of course there is the question what
happens if black does not take the pawn
which is what we're going to look at now
which is knight to a5
uh this is the move that fairgo played
in the game
but it's just not very good it's sort of
taking the positional approach to now a
very very severe threat
on the king's side right uh ivan is
playing his positional chess he's going
to go rook c8 build his nice little
blockade on the queen side but it's not
going to matter if if the king is dead
just for reference i think the only move
that i looked at that i was satisfied
wasn't totally lost was queen d5
and this was actually john timmon's
choice in a game against uh vichy and on
and it looks very dangerous for black
still and in fact black did go on to
lose this game against anand but at
least it wasn't to check me anons you
know did some funny business on the
queen's side and then eventually did do
things like a4 and ended up switching
switching ideas playing on the queen
slide
so i wanted to throw that move out but
knight a5 is our move in the game
of course what's our follow-up to h4 we
played h4 not necessarily to play h5 h6
when again our own pawn kind of gets in
the way but to play knight g5 the idea
that everybody
everybody loves now
the greek gift isn't actually going to
be quite as good here because after
knight g5 we can take and you don't have
a rook on h1 to finish the checkmate
but thankfully knight g5 itself is a
pretty good move
okay so we play knight g5 uh you know
big whoop we have attacked
on the king side and are now inducing a
weakness either g6 or or h6 so
what is our points against the move g6
what ideas come to mind here how what
are some themes to uh to break down this
structure
just sack just sack it all right so how
do we want a sack
okay it takes
king g8 otherwise i get checked on h6
yeah that's that's exactly right you
sack it all
um and white's just winning here um but
i will say you do have to be pretty
brave to play this because
uh now that the road to victory is
actually pretty narrow you take on e6
which seems obvious but this move r rook
f6 is a little bit scary um you have to
play queen h5 which again is obvious you
save the queen with check
king g8
and then actually the only move that
wins here is rookie five rookie three is
no good because bishop d6 happens and
then you're down two pieces and can't
play your g3 and things get ugly but
rookie five is good enough and white
comes to to attack the king for example
rick f7 bishop h6 and
you've seen these these games before i'm
sure bishop f8 check
and in the long run uh black's king is
just not going to survive
okay probably not rookie 8 i think i
meant to play that move but uh you get
the idea
so against g6 we have successfully
stopped black's idea of coming uh to
defend with this bishop on g7 we stopped
it just by taking all the pawns and then
and then checkmating black king which is
pretty good
why not rookie five instead of rookie
six um i think rookie five is good it's
just not quite as good as rook e6
because black has rook f5 in this
instance and then your best move is to
go rookie 6 and i think black's best
move is rook f6 and then you've
transposed
um yeah but rook f5 is the answer
so against g6 we have this really crazy
idea stacking all our pieces ripping
open the black king and then playing for
checkmate
which is again an important motif to
remember now against h6 this is what was
played in the game so what do you think
our idea is going to be now now that
we've induced h6
do any common attacking themes come to
mind
manny says one more move to time control
yeah
it's a little bit risky to try these
repetitions in a
in crazy positions like that you know
the odds that you miss something are
kind of there okay everybody agrees
everybody agrees the amazing move queen
h5 and this was played in the game but
it is amazingly not the best move i was
just as shocked as you were
alpha zero says what about knight takes
c6 and uncharacteristically i think
alpha zero has the wrong idea here
um this knight is helping us attack the
king right now and we can play something
like queen h5
and preserve our knight on the square
and we would rather keep this knight
later to to sacrifice that at the
correct opportunity you know this knight
on g5 is very very good we don't
necessarily want to give it up just yet
and taking these six might actually ease
black's problems a little bit by
allowing this rick to step forward and
help defend
um so amazingly
queen h5 is not the right idea
you know i was very very shocked
so what's wrong with queen h5 what's
what's the point and i'm actually going
to ask you guys at home this question
because i think it's a really really
nice idea and it's one that shows up uh
not uh
not rarely it shows up quite a bit
actually so
we have this queen bearing down on the
king side
we have pressure on the f7 pawn and we
have pressure on this diagonal
so black's next move is going to to stop
uh our main threat here so our main
threat as people in the chat are saying
is we want to go knight h7 and then as
uh aaron is quoting sack
sack
and mate we we take on h6 we go queen h6
and we we just rip open the king's side
and win although okay now i'm realizing
aaron was talking about the knight h7
line um but yeah knight h7 here is our
main threat like if black does nothing
we go net h7
we go bishop h6
we just take this guy
and we we attack the king with our net
in h7 with our bishop here can bring in
a rook it's going to be very very
dangerous so that's our threat
but black has actually a very clever
clever way to to stop the threat
manny has the right idea but maybe in
the wrong order so
work on that one a little bit more manny
and then i think you'll have a you'll
have our answer
uh bishop f6 might actually make things
worse uh i'll look at bishop f6 really
quickly but if we go knight h7
move the rook
um
i might be mistaken nah we don't have
the same trick with going bishop g5
but uh
i think we could actually go bishop g5
first i was thinking that the queen
would be trapped here
but i think in this case you can't
actually capture this guy but if we go
bishop g5 first i think i i won't have
any such problems
and you're in big big danger for example
takes takes
um g6 i'm always going to take it
and if you don't play g6
you know i take here and
and you're in trouble and you're in
trouble
so manny has arrived at the right idea
queen e8 is the miracle resource for
black that's actually gonna keep black
in this game
uh after queen e8 it's it's hard to
continue moving forward with white so
what what is the point well the point is
actually after knight h7 black is
winning here with an amazing tactic so
if you haven't seen it yet try to find
it now um but the answer of course is
now we go f5 just completely locking
this bishop out putting the queens in
contact and now threatening to capture
the knight for free and believe it or
not black is totally winning after
knight h7f5 um we have to trade the
queens otherwise our knight just dies
um
okay i mean theoretically we could go
here but we're still just gonna be down
a piece
so we trade the queens but now black can
save the rook with tempo
and this knight is entirely trapped on
the h7 square rookie six
king h7 bishop f5 king g8
and black has more pieces you know what
what more uh what more is there to wants
so queen e8 would have been a really
stellar defensive resource to keep black
in the game and actually make white's
life rather difficult so with that in
mind is there a better move here than
queen h5
is there a better move here than queen
h5
super curious says knight takes e6 again
this is going to make black's life
easier you know it you you get a couple
pawns but black's rook is going to enter
the game and help defend and you've
actually given the king a better escape
route than he once had so 96 is no good
no good
manny says knight f3 so actually in this
lane with queen h5 queen e8 the best
that white can do is is actually retreat
with this knight either to f3 or i think
h3
and then you know continue the attack a
little bit more slowly we're threatening
stuff like this threatening g4 g5 now
with with a little bit more of a severe
threat on the h6 pawn
g4 not good when all three pawns are
here but when the h6 pawn has been
induced forward we can sometimes use
that as a hook to open things up
but the point is we can improve over
queen h5 uh by continuing on forward
and webster actually has the right
answer this time it's knight h7 first of
course just not allowing this queen e8
idea so after rookie 8
now we could continue with queen h5 and
this i think would would transpose to
the the game
the game line
um
although i'm now realizing there's
queen d5 here what am i missing i think
maybe queen g4 in this instance is is
the idea and against queen d5 we would
now have bishop e4 sorry i think i mixed
up my lines there yeah it is queen g
queen g4 here and
all the same threats that we've been
talking about are going to be very very
strong
um so knight h7 first and it might not
seem that important whether you go queen
h5 or knight h7 but it's always
important to be aware of your opponent's
defensive resources and
sort of putting yourself in yourself in
their shoes like you know if i were
black how would i try to get out of this
and queen h528 would actually give white
a very difficult time forward here like
you have to find moves like knight h3
just retreating so that you can continue
attacking later
of course white is still going to be
better after queen e8 but
you do have to retreat
and of course this queen e8 idea
actually reminded me of a very famous
game
between bobby fischer and benko
which if you guys know at home bobby's a
mortal rook f6 move uh is the one i'm
talking about so be sure to look up that
game if you if you haven't seen it
um yeah so queenie8 uh as the in-person
audience is coming back who's also named
caleb uh knight h7 f5 and black is
actually winning uh as we were saying
this knight is completely trapped and
takes takes you can't get this knight
out
um
but queen e8 not found in the game queen
h5 bishop d5 played and this just does
allow knight h7 rookie 8 and then of
course i sort of already spoiled it but
how do we how do we attack now how can
we break through
yeah bishop h6 and black is is getting
getting crushed here um
so
after bishop h6 we get takes takes
f5 now but it's sort of too little too
late we needed to interfere with this
bishop but of course
how is white going to continue now
just rick e3 it's the the moves sort of
play themselves this rook on e1 might
not seem like it's doing a lot at first
i remember in the opening we just played
this random rookie one move but bringing
the rook to the open file really allows
all sorts of attacking opportunities as
well this is a very important attacking
piece even though it starts out on the
first rank without looking like it's
doing much aside from pressuring maybe
the e file but rookie 3 to g3 is going
to be a deadly idea in a lot of these
positions
um black went a little bit crazy now
played bishop takes h4
and it's time to find uh some knockout
punches here time to find some knockout
punches so
uh this is now a tactics puzzle for
those of you at home
how do we
put the final nails in the coffin here
for ivan
someone in the chat says knight of six
knight f6 would be great but it can be
captured
maybe like this
and maybe with the queen
and then
okay manny says queen g6 check king h8
rook h3
um the only problem with that is you
didn't make a threat i'll play rook g8
and continue the game
and then i'll take on g2
and then
i'll ask you if you're even still
winning
rick age three first okay rook h3 might
might win but uh it's not nearly as fun
as uh
as the game continuation
okay so we can do everything with checks
here that's my hint we can do everything
with checks
aside from you know the end
yeah rook h3 uh maybe black can play
king to f7 and
uh you might be getting your piece back
but i don't know if you're checkmating
me right away like rick takes h4 king e7
for example and
i'm a runner
i am a runner
there you go rook g3 check the amazing
deflection getting rid of this bishop
and then then we're in business so
bishop takes g3 what's the follow up
knight f6
they come this way so what do we do
yeah i mean okay not not all checks but
here we go manny's got the right line we
go queen g6 first stopping king f7 king
h8 and then bam knight f6 is is gonna be
game over
knight f6 and the point is
uh if you try to defend
check
and mate
same if you defend with the rook or rich
g8 or anything just too many threats
here to stop
so you have to get really creative
um
or sacrifice the queen and this is
actually the game line and ivan came up
with the the killer bishop to h2 check
the move that nobody saw coming
um and of course the point is if you
take you're gonna get checked
and then with two pieces defending along
the rank black is not yet checkmated but
white found the right idea here you just
move out of the way and then you know
nothing nothing really happening for
black so black sacrifices the queen
and they played on for a while
but uh black has all the same problems
we're gonna go with check check and ivan
decided to resign now that he's losing a
second rook
white just very calmly plays rook h1 and
moves the king out of the way
and all the attacking power is is still
there so that was the the nice uh finish
to the game here rook g3 check
amazing move getting rid of the bishop
and then we have this nice checkmating
pattern from before
so let's look at this start to finish
and sort of talk about the key concepts
here
because it's nice to look at a game like
this
and just calculate calculate calculate
but to actually take something away from
it to incorporate in your games
it's useful to look at a lot of these
attacking ideas especially when there's
no knight on f6 that should kind of be
your first cue hey maybe i can attack on
the king's side here because i have all
these open diagonals black doesn't have
the f6 knight to help defend against
these ideas
and it looks like black's king is a
little bit lonely
so you notice that you might have some
kind of attacking idea
and then you look for these common
patterns these common themes um which
now you have seen before you look for
ways to take on h7 or to pressure h7 uh
you look for ways to induce weakness
with either g6 or h6
and from this game we actually learned
quite a bit we learned about um
this uh this pattern which i mean some
of you might have seen before um as
someone in the chat mentioned this is
bobby fischer's famous sac sack mate
this is what he's talking about um
like this knight h7 idea is is really
really useful to just have in your
arsenal you know against g6 when i can
have this knight on g5 this is a
sacrifice to look for a sacrifice to
calculate and against h6 now you know
these ideas queen age five you know look
out for this queen e8 idea because this
does show up uh quite often
and you know about knight h7 um you know
revealing this bishop uh behind the
knight allowing it to sacrifice
and you know about this rook lift as
well like these are all uh themes that
are gonna show up over and over again in
positions like this in positions where
you're trying to attack the castled king
uh and so that's the point that i want
you guys to take away even if you don't
consciously memorize these ideas
it's really useful to pay attention and
notice when when they're coming up in
your games and if you miss something
like this in your games
now you know to be on the lookout
because they show up they're not
uncommon and they are great ways to to
win the game you just attack in the
middle game you find all these great
ideas and and you crush
but the the subtle idea that i wouldn't
expect people to find is h4 in this
position realizing from such a tame
looking position that you can play
something like h4 and just launch into
this uh super tactical sequence where
you're attacking the black king and
winning with mate is is hard to do
but it's all about looking for those key
signs the knight on f6 is missing we
have long open diagonals our center is
very secure thanks to this knight takes
c3 business um and so why not go for an
attack
probably 95 was not good maybe bishop f6
was more useful yeah again the the best
move that i've seen played here i did a
little bit of analysis
it was this queen d5 move by by john
timmon that was played against uh
uh vishyanan's and the idea is very
simple you centralize the queen you
increase some some threats against uh
white's king and you just have too much
counter play to go for the same kinds of
attacks
uh that we were looking at before
um so queen d5 and if you want to look
at that game you can look at that game
but you know obviously if black plays
well then he doesn't lose by checkmate
so uh black has to make some mistake in
the game and knight to a5 is one of
those as well as not playing queenie
eight here was was the real end of the
game that's when white was just totally
winning
but super fun game okay so any questions
from the audience here any questions on
this game
isn't queen d5 running into bishop e4 uh
maybe let's look
so bishop e4
maybe black is uh you know coming in to
defend a little bit something like queen
h5 tries to highlight that this h4 pawn
might be a little bit weak and it's very
different from when the queen ended up
on h4 because white has all these pieces
in the way black still has this dark
square bishop and uh and life is good i
might also be missing some other
tactical justification but i think
something like queen h5 is is going to
be useful for black
um just as an example line queen h5
uh knight g5 i can take and tactically
this shouldn't work for you because
too many threats
um and if you just take back i'll take
the knight and
same sort of deal black is surviving
could black not take h4 i would suggest
you go back in the lecture a little bit
we talked about uh bishop h4 when we
first looked at this move
uh okay
let's move on to another game so that
was one example of
a crushing kingside attack with
an isolated queen pawn which is one type
of position but of course not all games
are going to be the same and while this
is a common attacking structure for
white it's definitely not the only one
so i wanted to look at something sort of
radically different now i go over a lot
of d4 games in my lectures because
that's what i like to play
but uh we're going to look at a game
between uh two alexanders alexandra
toulouse and alexander kotov two super
strong russians from back in the mid
1900s i think i think toulouse was uh
a coach or something for boris baskey
way back in the day so these guys knew
their stuff and here we're going to be
looking at a sicilian so we get e4 c5
knight f3 e6
d4 take take
knight f6 knight c3 d6 and just g3 uh by
alexander klush excuse me
just g3
so white is taking maybe a more
conservative approach compared to the
main line with g4 where you are going
for this garbage
right out of the opening instead white
is going to develop first with g3
we get nine c6 and we're in a chevy
engine by the way uh bishop g2 just
calmly fee and kettling wing bishop d7
uh and then white plays this kind of kg
move
knight d to e2 so what's the point of
this move well the point is black would
likely uh appreciate bringing this
bishop out to c6
and if you do something like castles uh
maybe one day knight takes d4 and bishop
c6 is going to come so white instead
plays knight d to e2 to keep these
pieces on the board make black's life a
little bit harder with the lack of space
to put these pieces on comfortable
squares definitely
not the main main idea in the opening
though just kind of a cagey uh i maybe
it was a novelty at the time maybe not
just a kg idea to make black's life a
little bit harder
a6 played in the game we get castles b5
white plays this move a3 just trying to
slow down black's b4 counter play
and now we get queen to c7
so once again we have uh just sort of a
random chess position out of the opening
so the question is now you know
judging by the topic of the class you
might have an idea of what we're going
to be doing but how do we organize our
pieces what kind of ideas are we going
for in this instance because it's a very
very different kind of position and it's
going to be a very different kind of
attack from an isolated queen pond
position because the structure's just
totally different black hasn't even
castled yet
and so we have to definitely play a lot
differently
and while you're thinking daniel has a
question he says do you always calculate
concretely when you do a sacrifice or
can you simply decide based on intuition
um well it depends if you're playing in
a tournament game and you have time on
your clock you should calculate
concretely if you're playing in a
tournament game you don't have time on
your clock and sometimes intuition has
to be enough but
when in doubt when given the choice
between calculating and not calculating
you should always calculate it's it's
basically cheating calculating you just
get to know the truth of the position if
you do it correctly
instead of guessing
okay so there's some ideas in the chats
uh vlodimir says we have to decide what
to do with the dark squared bishop and
that's not necessarily true um you saw
it in the last game as well actually but
often times start squared bishop is the
last piece to get developed and that's
for good reason because we don't
actually know where we want it yet we
haven't decided maybe it's good on e3
maybe it'll want to come out and
sacrifice on h6 like in last game maybe
it'll come to g5 maybe even to f4 if
this uh diagonal opens up
and maybe somewhere else maybe b4 bishop
b2 or something crazy so we don't really
know what to do with this bishop yet so
a lot of times it's better just to leave
it on c1 it's out of the way it's not
going to get harassed by black pieces
and once you know where it belongs then
you can move it
some other ideas in the chat were f4
this is definitely going to be
a common theme here h3 has been
suggested as well
and then yeah bishop b3 bishop f4 also
suggested uh in this position
and so i really do like leaving this
bishop on c1 for the moment because once
you decide on a square then black sort
of knows what you're up to and can adapt
his play based on on where you move to
um but yeah i like this move h3 to start
this is actually what's played in the
game and after bishop e7
i really like uh white's next move
um it's
i always joke it's the quintessential
karpovian move in these positions when
you want to attack soon but you need to
play a super good improving move first
what do you do of course you play king
h1 just
sidestepping all of the stuff
and slowly but surely getting ready to
play stuff like f4 you don't want to do
this too early because then you just
open up your king to all sorts of
nasty counter-attacking ideas
some of the chat says king h2 so why
wouldn't we want to go to king h2 well
we might want to move this pawn as well
and then same exact thing we don't want
our king on this open diagonal so king
h1 castles and then white actually
starts with this nice move g4 and this
move next to e2 is starting to make a
little bit more sense so
g4
and white's attacking setup now is
actually going to revolve around
bringing this knight to g3 and using
this knight to help support both the
center and some nice attacking ideas you
got you all know about knights landing
on f5 knights landing on h5 can also be
pretty dangerous as well attacking the
king and so after king h8 we get knight
g3
um okay
b4 played in the game for black trying
to go for counter play white captures
black captures and now
it's up to us to again decide how we're
going to continue
our attack here so rather than the last
game which we saw the attack kind of
being led by pieces
in this instance there's something
different uh this knight is still on f6
and believe it or not that one knight
makes all all the difference you know it
guards this square it guards this square
and it makes it very difficult for white
to just sort of come in and attack like
we saw last time white's pieces are also
not quite as well placed as we saw last
time right this bishop is going to have
a hard time attacking this king's side
it's it's aiming this way instead
so because of all that because white
doesn't have these super active pieces
sometimes it's better to lead with the
pawns
okay the chat says f4 i think f4 is
probably just as good but white actually
starts with g5 because why not start
with g5 you kick this knight out of the
way by the way this is the reason why
king h8 was played black wants to bring
this knight to g8 rather than e8 to help
defend uh some of these squares
so knight g8 played and then yes
f4 is is the follow-up in the game
so knight g8 f4 bishop c6
okay so we've played g5 we played f4 now
again how are we continuing
our attack is it time to bring in the
pieces
is it time to
continue with the pawns what do we want
to do
asks doesn't e5 win material um i don't
think so
i don't think so i think e5 you're gonna
run into knight d5
and black's doing okay
daryl asks can you ask what justifies
such an attack with an open center and
light squared bishops and queens still
on the board it's just that white played
bishop g2 early
um yeah so some of it is white can get
away with pushing these pawns because
this bishop is a great defender of the
king um outside of that white can get
away with pushing these pawns because
the center is actually not open an open
center is that would be if these three
pawns were gone and then this would be
psychotic these three pawns are here
it's sort of semi-open it's still a
fluid center it's you know subject to
change
um so it might open up but white might
be able to keep it closed and might keep
things under control
and the justification is that black has
less space you know when you have more
space you can attack more often than not
and so because white has all this space
and dwight uh decided that black
couldn't open the center in time
that's what allows him to go for this
kind of attack on king's side now
judging the specifics of that are always
going to be difficult and it's it's
going to be very concrete thing that's
why
you know
platitudes like when your opponent
attacks on the flank counter in the
center don't always get you far in chess
you have to look at the specifics see
well is the attack on the flank coming
faster than the attack in the center or
is the attack in the center going to be
worthwhile
but that's the justification is white
has more space
the center isn't open yet
and white's attack is coming quickly
okay the chat is all better than
alexander toulouse f5 is the best move
and i think that this is the natural
idea the natural continuation for for
white in this position
uh now why didn't white play f5 well
probably white was looking at uh this
pawn coming to d5 and maybe didn't like
something about this
where
uh we can no longer keep things closed
with something like e5 for example let's
compare what uh let's compare that line
to in the game uh in the game white
plays this weird looking move knight c
to e2 once again two weird knight
retreats but against this i think white
would be very very happy to play
something like e5 here keep the center
closed and then slowly ratchet up the
pressure on the king's side while
occupying this d4 outpost so i i think
this d5 move was the reason why
uh black shied away from f5 because f5
d5
it does turn out that you're in time to
do stuff like knight h5 and attack but
let's say you play like one slow move
something like queen g4 i think uh d
takes e4 and now you do start to regret
all these pawn pushes that you've made
because if the center does fully open up
like daryl in the chat was asking
then you can run into some trouble here
with white you definitely can run into
trouble
um queen g4 might also hang this pawn by
the way but i think this is more more
relevant at least to start with
knight c2 might also be included
um
but yeah it turns out you can play
knight h5 and
stuff like f6 is is coming way too
quickly
and you're going to end up in some
position like this where this knight is
sort of entirely entombed and black is
in a lot of trouble
black might not be getting checkmated
right away because this knight well
entombed does defend the h6 square but
having an entombed knight probably means
that black is going to lose this game
so i think f5 is correct but you have to
be aware of these counter punches so you
have to be aware of d5 have to be aware
of what black is is up to
um instead knight d to e2 is played
black comes up with this nice move
bishop to b5 and then white has this
really nice idea to both activate this
bishop and defend c2 uh and he does so
by playing bishop to d2 if you don't
play bishop to d2 i think white is is
actually going to be worse in this
position because it is very risky to
push all these pawns and black is is
getting active
uh so bishop to d2 how does this defend
c2 well if you take with the knight rook
to c1 is going to be strong and if you
take with the queen that hangs knight so
simple enough
black continues now with d5 but we can
see that's uh white is a lot better
prepared for it now the dark squared or
black's light squared bishop is no
longer on this diagonal and he can
continue now with with bishop to c3
fully activating this bishop on this
diagonal once again useful to wait with
that bishop now now we know this is the
critical diagonal in the game this is
the soft spot in black's camp and so
bishop to c3 is where this bishop
belongs
we get d takes e4 in the game
and now once again
how are we going to continue here how do
we crack
black's castle
yeah knight h5 is great knight h5 is
great and there's
really only one move that doesn't hang a
piece or g7 and that is f6 so what
what's the points now what is the points
queen d4 again queen d4 like in the last
game isn't going to be as good because
the queen is actually pretty well placed
on d1 uh to
come into the the king side and continue
the attack uh much more so than it would
be on d4
i think you're also running into an e5
idea if you play queen d4 that's why
it's not winning a piece
um yeah i was just saying i think you
run into this e5 idea as well and and
the queen is better placed on d1 um but
i understand that this just looks like a
fork but i think e5 is is going to be
saving the day
and something like this
is is going to be getting active once
again for for black
i'm actually going to check this though
because i might be wrong and i didn't
see this idea yeah e5 is is saving the
day for for black
um and if take
okay now bishop c5 is fine but knight c2
is is even better just
really rubbing it in that you can't jump
over your own pieces
uh just queen e4 and now you play this
position
which is fine i think this it said
equality here or something uh white's
slightly better but yeah
uh definitely not the the crushing ideas
that we're looking for
sorry so we had knight h5 uh f6
and then yeah subakura has has the right
idea we just take that g7 pawn off the
board just come right after uh black's
king so knight g7 and
i will admit that i to me this idea
seems a lot less common than the ideas
we looked at in the previous game but
it's important to notice like
whenever things seem to be getting
locked up with the pawns the the common
theme is always going to be some kind of
sacrifice
on the pawns is needed to fully rip it
open unless you just have sort of a free
attack um so knight g7 is the idea here
we found the soft spot in black's camp
with our bishop and our knight working
together and then we just sacrifice to
to finish opening it up
in this position amazingly black is
actually not busted but he has to find
rook d8
when after knight e6 rook d1 knight c7
um
you can take this piece and
these lines are sort of confusing but
equality just according to the computer
equality so so there you go
um but barring that uh black tried to
play this move uh bishop takes e2 and
the reason for that is we play king
takes g7 knight d4 is going to be the
idea when this is a threat and this is a
threat and you can't really stop
everything so black solution was to take
the knight off the board but
unfortunately this does just lose after
queen e2
king to g7
once again how do we bring in the pieces
how do we bring in the pieces now
yeah just just queen h5 and bishop b4 to
come actually okay bishop b4 played
first in this case it it shouldn't
matter um
okay actually it might matter maybe if
you go queen h5 first black is going to
try to defend this pawn so bishop b4
first and then we come with queen h5 and
black just doesn't have time to
eliminate this bishop because of
checkmating threats
in the game rook d8 was tried to give
the king a flight square
but now we just go rook g1 and finish
opening opening things up over here
bishop c5 but white doesn't even care
just take on f6 double check
and now
wait to move and win
as we're
a couple minutes over time here let's
wrap it up white to move and win anybody
can you be the hero to uh to put black
out of his misery
yeah something tells you rick g8 and
that would be the correct answer
but why is that the answer what do we
have here
zack moore that's right
they didn't tell you the follow-up they
just told you rick gate
yeah so it's actually a really really
nice idea here
yeah just bishop h7 and if queen takes
f7 and the king cannot stay in contact
with the queen
and if the queen takes we have checkmate
nasty business nasty business so king f8
was played in the game and this game
does last a little while longer but the
result is no longer in doubt and white
can do a number of things and still win
uh namely take all the pieces with check
is normally good enough so
check check check takes this piece
check check check check check
check
check
and black resigns
this is hanging it's also like just
checkmate in a few here and that that's
the end of the game
so just another example of how attacks
can can sort of come together you know
you look for weak spots in the camp and
your enemies camp and you try and find
common themes common sacrificial ideas
non-sacrificial ideas to to break things
open you know not everything has to be a
sacrifice for example in this game just
the simple f5 f6 i think was was the
correct way to go about things uh what
white did does allow some opportunities
for for black to fight back with you
know even still d5 and we saw
some crazy lines where black is
equalizing
so the point of this lecture was to show
you guys all these fun attacking themes
attacking ideas and talk a little bit
about what to look for in your games you
know you you got to be
vigilant you got to be looking for these
ideas otherwise they will they will pass
you by in sometimes seemingly you know
innocuous positions
uh with that i think i'm gonna wrap up
the road to 2000 for tonight we should
have grand master atonis kolev coming in
shortly with uh insane in the end game i
believe it's time to get insane so stick
around for that as always thank you all
very much for watching my name is caleb
denby and i will see you next time
[Music]
you